so the movie pretty much begins kind of
like in the comic book which is you know
my mom and dad meet under the
circumstances and and they fall in love
and they have a child and the child
grows up to become Arthur Carey and one
of the things I wanted to show early on
is showed that he doesn't quite fit into
into the into the surface woman so he
gets picked on her when he was a kid but
but because he's different and and he is
obviously a sequence where we see him
getting picked on in an aquarium and
because he's talking to fish but then
that boy would grow up to become Jason
Momoa someone that that you don't really
want to mess with and then yeah and then
basically Mara comes to the surface to
to appeal to him telling him that we
need your help because your half-brother
king Oram is about to declare war on the
surface well because he's had enough
with that crap that uh that we've been
you know do we have no respect for the
planet and we treat the world horribly
and so Aquaman then Arthur has to take
that journey to atlantis' this is what
we see here Atlantis for the first time
and and ask the audience in the movie
get to experience Atlantis for the first
time along with our hero so here's to go
back there take on his brother challenge
his brother to the combat of the King to
to prove who's the right ear the right
person for the throne because Arthur
technically is the heir to the throne
because it's the firstborn but obviously
his brother doesn't want to give it up
that easily his brother played by the
amazing Patrick Wilson and then you know
we see so if other scenes where he's
training to be too you know training by
Willem Dafoe volcko and Amber Heard
plays Mara who is pretty much his other
half and they go on this incredible
journey around the world to on this
amazing quest to try and do what they
have to do to stop this war from coming
to the surface world and and it's a
classic action adventure story very much
in the spirit of early Spielberg early
George Lucas
and classic Cameron as well and this
movie I hope really captured the spirit
of the comic book and and what we love
in these kind of films I hope you guys
come and see the movie
hey everybody its charlie so James Wan
the director of Aquaman did commentary
on some specific plot points they
recontextualized some of the events of
Justice League going all the way back to
Man of Steel in there were a couple of
scenes that they screened at comic-con
that they did not release on line 3
specifically so I'll explain the footage
that was in those scenes in what these
special Justice League Easter eggs were
so if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
there's a new brand of that flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video I'll name a new
winner at the end of this so he explains
specifically why Aurum is attacking the
surface world also clarifies the
pronunciation of his name so or um's
rage against the surface world goes all
the way back to Man of Steel also
confirmed by another Easter Egg from the
Shazam trailer - there are a couple
Aquaman Easter eggs during the Shazam
trailer but what happened is is because
of all the attacks that have happened
when the Kryptonians came during Man of
Steel and started tearing the planet up
and then later during Justice League
when Steppenwolf started tearing the
planet up is that it did major damage to
Earth's oceans so even though the seven
nations of Atlantis have been divided
since it sank 5,000 years ago
he's the descendant of the original
ruler of all those seven different
kingdoms
so naturally he feels like it's his
responsibility to do something about
this so he blames humanity for all the
things that happen during these big Man
of Steel Justice League attacks he's
using that to reunite the nation
so obviously Aquaman also unites the
seven is doing the same thing but for
very different reasons so it's funny how
the new movies are sort of
recontextualizing the events of the past
movies whether or not that was always
the plan they do the same thing during
the Shazam movie with all the Easter
eggs and Freddy Freeman's house when you
look you sell the newspaper articles it
turns out that the world blames Lex
Luthor for what happened during Batman V
Superman which I feel like is also sort
of back door setup for a possible in
Justice League movie or an injustice
movie they met just shorten it if they
want to do that in the future like they
teased at the end of Justice League but
because of all the stuff that's happened
in the past couple of years no idea if
that film will actually
come to fruition they haven't said
anything about an Aquaman sequel but
they did say that Black Manta would be
featured in other DC films but it would
be that Lex Luthor injustice film just
because he was a member of that team
during the comics so the three scenes
that they screened exclusively in Hall H
that they didn't release online are one
is a flashback showing how he was born
it's just an extended version of what
you see at the beginning of the trailer
where his mother washes up on the shore
his father rescues her they have a life
together but eventually she does have to
go back to become ruler of Atlantis the
second one is much more important it
picks up right after they jump out of
the plane at the end of the trailer here
they're in the desert and they find
these special ruins where they go and
they see the special technology left by
King at land where he tells them that
there's this special trident that used
to belong to him that was intended to
unite the surface world with the nations
of Atlantis
so unites the seven I think you know
back to our confirmation that the
seventh kingdom of Atlantis is actually
what we know as the surface world like
surprise the United States people in
Europe people in Africa all over the
world are the seventh nation of Atlantis
meaning that only six are underwater but
what happens is is they get the message
from at land to unite the seven to find
the Trident there's a couple funny
moments where Aquaman's like yeah yeah
yeah Trident whatever I got it let's go
they smashed the hologram device so that
Aurum can't find it then they leave and
they get chased down by Black Manta you
see a version of that during the trailer
where he's blasting them with his eye
beams like that's right after they find
out about to try and get the message
from at land they also explain why the
desert is so important because it used
to be underwater five thousand years ago
before Atlantis sank the third scene was
from the very end of the film it was
just voice over and then a bit of a
costume reveal it's Meera saying to
Jason Momoa 'he's character atlantis has
always had a king but now it needs
something different a hero then you get
the full reveal of him in the gold and
green scale armor from the comics so
just remember important idea is that
it's not just about uniting the undersea
nations of Atlantis the sixth is about
bringing the nations of Atlantis in the
surface world together which is why I
think the secret seventh kingdom is the
surface world doesn't that just feel
like one of those big blockbuster movie
twists like oh not
everybody sank with Atlantis 5,000 years
ago some people continued to live on the
surface and they eventually populated
the nations that we see in the world
today but if you didn't spot it there
was another really cool Aquaman Easter
Egg during the Shazam trailer where he's
trying to fly there's that big
skateboard ramp on the side it says
Aryan they've changed Aquaman's origin
story a couple times in the comics but
before crisis on Infinite Earths
happened there was a miniseries called
Aryan Lord of Atlantis and in that story
the ancient ruler of Atlantis before it
sank was a sorcerer named Aryan so it's
a very very deep cut but if you're
wondering or if you don't read the
comics right now sorcery and magic are a
big part of Atlantean culture so I'll be
interested to see how they explain that
during the movie because Shazam is kind
of like the first genuine magic movie
but because magic is such a big part of
Aquaman Comics they might get into that
too but maybe just a little bit one
example of the magic of Atlantis is the
giant dome that covers it and protects
it from the outside world and shields it
from view like that's the reason why
people haven't found it because there's
a magical barrier just like the barrier
that protects the mascara but let me
know in the comments if you spotted any
other big Easter eggs that I didn't
mention in the video Jeff Jones also did
say that the Green Lantern Corps movie
was gonna be a total reboot of that
franchise so it won't have any relation
to what they did with the last Ryan
Reynolds Green Lantern movie but there
wasn't really any other big DC movie
news at the panel there was some new
details on the flash 100th episode this
season so I will do a video about that
soon I'm also working on my non-spoilery
Mission Impossible fallout review so
that should post really soon
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Calhoun's or please email me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details click here to
rewatch the flash season 5 trailer and
click here to re-watch that Shazam
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]